hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein kleines basic video
und zwar weil ich von meinen zuschauern
immer wieder gefragt wann nehme ich von
dort war nämlich blüten passte waren
nämlich modelliert schokolade oder
marzipan
ich bin erzählt die vier produkte immer
ganz gerne in meinen videos wenig motiv
torten mache aber ich habe noch kein
video darüber gemacht wann man welches
produkt am besten verwendet in diesem
video gibt deswegen so ein paar
grundlagen und ich würde jetzt einfach
mal sagen ich starte einfach direkt mit
dem fondant fondant besteht zum größten
teil aus zucker das ist eine zucker über
zugs masse und die eignet sich
hervorragend um damit torten
einzukleiden
wenn man es mit von land arbeitet muss
man nur darauf achten dass die torten
vorher entsprechend behandelt werden
man darf nämlich keine sahne krebs zum
beispiel verwenden
da der fonds sich anschließen sonst
auflösen würde der perfekte unterlage
für sondern ist zum beispiel ein mal
lecker nach das ist eine schokoladen
sahne creme oder eine französische
buttercreme die aus eiern und mutter
besteht wenn ich jetzt eine sahnetorte
mit fondant überziehen möchte dann kann
ich die sahne eben nur als füllung
verwenden und kann außen rumba neben
galas oder französische buttercreme
streichen
für den von dort habe ich auch schon ein
eigenes video gemacht und da gibt es
dann auch noch weitere infos wenn man
jetzt den von dann nicht nur als überzug
nehmen möchte sondern zum beispiel auch
damit modellieren möchte dann muss man
modelle von land herstellen
und dafür benötigt man einerseits zum
beispiel etwas cmc pulver und zwar ist
es zellulose pulver reines sinnlose
pulver und dieses bewegt dass die masse
dann festwirt und aushärtet und dadurch
wird sie eben richtig schön hart und ich
zeige euch jetzt mal wie man
modelliermasse herstellt um modelle von
land herzustellen kann man cmc pulver
alte zellulose pulver in fondant ein
kneten da benötigt man etwa einen
teelöffel pro 500 gramm sondern oder man
vermischt blüten passt und fondant eins
zu eins habe ich jetzt 100 kampf sondern
und 100 computer passt
mit diesem modell von sand kann man
jetzt beispielsweise figuren herstellen
die dann eben ganz gut aus herten
jetzt geht es weiter mit der blüten
passte die habe ich ja eben schon bei
der mutter lief fondant angesprochen
blüten passte kann man selbst herstellen
oder auch bereits fertig kaufen
das gibt es auch in verschiedenen farben
und zwar besteht es einmal aus eiweiß
und aus zellulose also hier finden wir
auch das cellulose pulver wieder mit
drinnen und zwar ist die blüten passte
super dafür geeignet um filigrane blüten
herzustellen wie beispielsweise rosen
oder eben alle anderen blüten die man
kennt und damit kann man wirklich sehr
fein arbeiten und die blüten passte auch
sehr dünn ausrollen und wenn sie bei
raumtemperatur steht und nicht abgedeckt
wird dann hättet sie auch komplett aus
deswegen kann man mit der blüten passte
wirklich gut
von land an mischen und daraus eben
modelliermasse herstellen blüten passte
eignet sich aber nicht so über 10 von
torten
das heißt damit wirklich nur werden nur
blüten hergestellt oder man kann es eben
zum anmischen verwenden
jetzt geht es weiter mit der modelliert
schokolade und die hart wie der name
schon sagt richtige schokolade mit
drinnen wird gibt es da wirklich
unterschiede also ich verwende ganz
gerne die modelle schokolade von deco
bock von d kino und zwar ist da wirklich
25 prozent echte schokolade mit drin
es gibt natürlich auch andere produkte
die sind darauf wahrscheinlich viel
preiswerter und günstiger aber da ist
dann einfach weniger schokoladen anteil
mit drin und die modelle schokolade die
schmeckt auch richtig nach weißer
schokolade und von der konsistenz her
ist sie einfach ein bisschen fester als
fondant und eignet sich auch zum
überziehen von torten
nur ist es ein bisschen schwieriger als
am anfang empfehle ich immer torten mit
vom baum zu überziehen
weil modelliert schokolade einfach ein
bisschen fester ist aber sie eignet sich
hervorragend zum modellieren von blumen
zum beispiel jetzt nicht von ganz
filigranen blumen wie jetzt mit der
blüten passte aber man kann auch damit
so ein bisschen dicke rosenmachen
dickere blüten machen und man kann
hervorragend das mit figuren modellieren
und das tolle bei der modelle schokolade
ist dass sie eben durch die körperwärme
warm wird also wenn sie
etwas geknetet wird wird sie warm und
sobald sie wieder auskühlt wird sie fest
das heißt ich habe auch lange genug zeit
um meine figuren damit zu modellieren
und auch immer wieder so ein bisschen
nach zu streichen falten weg zu
streichen weil es einfach ganz gut mit
der körper wärme geht
und deswegen ist sie wirklich ideal für
anfänger geeignet und schmeckt natürlich
auch hervorragend
und wenn man die modellierten sachen aus
modelliert schokolade ein bisschen
stehen lässt werden sie wie gesagt hat
und hätten dann auch aus wenn man torten
mit modelle schokolade überzieht dann
muss man auch nicht auf den untergrund
aufpassen denn die modelle schokolade
löst sich auf sahnetorten zum beispiel
nicht auf das heißt da ist komplett egal
was für einen untergrund man verwendet
und die kann einfach überall trümmer
gelegt werden
und zu guter letzt habe ich jetzt noch
marzipan und zwar spreche ich jetzt hier
vom modell ihr marzipan und jetzt nicht
von marzipanrohmasse zum backen
verwendet nämlich ganz gerne
marzipanrohmasse dann nehme ich meist
den lübecker marzipan weil er einfach
qualitativ sehr hoch ist und wirklich
auch aus lübeck kommt und viel mandl
anteil enthält aber zu modellieren und
dekorieren verwendet man ein modell ihr
marzipan und zwar ist der bereits
vermischt mit puderzucker und ist
einfach von der konsistenz her etwas
fester als jetzt liebt kac fan und dann
gibt's auch schon bereits eingefärbt um
mit marzipan kann man auch jegliche
torten eindecken das heißt ich kann auch
sagen torten damit eindecken und
überziehen und ich kann auch figuren
modellieren
der einzige nachteil oder sage ich jetzt
mal vor und nachteil ist das marzipan
natürlich den eigenen geschmack hat
schmeckt ganz stark nach mandeln ich mag
es sehr gerne aber es gibt natürlich
auch menschen die kein marzipan mögen
und deswegen auch kein marzipan überzug
mögen und erwarte man lässt sich sehr
einfach verarbeiten
es ist sehr weich und anschmiegsam und
ist auch wirklich total für anfänger
geeignet
der einzige nachteil ist dass matze war
nicht ganz so fein wie modelle
schokolade oder die blüten paste ist und
dass man einfach figuren zwar damit
modellieren kann aber dann eben nicht so
ganz glatte oberfläche aber es
funktioniert trotzdem wirklich super bei
allen produkten ist es so dass ich meine
hände vorher am liebsten mit etwas
kokosfett einreise dann klebt einfach
nicht so sehr
und wenn ich dann damit modellieren
möchte oder wenn ich es aus holen möchte
nehme ich einfach ein bisschen becker
stärker dazu und zwar ist becker stärke
reine kartoffelstärke und ich habe die
dann immer in so einem spender mit drin
und
dann schön die arbeitsfläche damit
ausstreuen oder zum beispiel auch meine
hände so ein bisschen vorher ein bruder
dann haben die modellierten sachen
einfach eine matte oberfläche
man kann alle produkte auch
untereinander mischen das heißt ich kann
zum beispiel orangen von land
herzustellen rot und gelb mischen oder
um hellrosa herzustellen rot und rosa
und weiß mischen oder ich nehme einfach
lebensmittel verpassten und da sollte
man wirklich auch darauf achten dass es
verpassten sind und keine flüssigen
farben weil die flüssigen farben einfach
nicht so pigmentiert sind und die
konsistenz der masse einfach zu sehr
verändern und diese verpassten sind sehr
gillard ich unser fest und haben
einfache wenig wasseranteil und eignen
sich deswegen viel besser zum einfärben
ein paar infos zur lagerung aufbewahrung
wird orten also alle torten dürfen im
kühlschrank gelagert werden so bald sie
eben mit vonlanthen oder limonade oder
marzipan überzogen sind
wichtig ist dabei nur dass der
kühlschrank nicht so feucht ist und
falls der kühlschrank doch ein bisschen
feucht ist könnt ihr einfach im
schälchen mit bisschen salz daneben
stellen neben die torte und das salz
saugt die feuchtigkeit auch und die
torte wird an dementsprechend nicht
feucht die produkte sind alle sobald sie
angebrochen sind auch mehrere wochen
haltbar
dafür müsste sie einfach ein bisschen
frischhaltefolie oder eine kleine tüte
luftdicht einpacken und die dann am
besten noch mal in eine dose luftdicht
aufbewahren und dann könnt ihr sie im
kühlschrank oder auch bei raumtemperatur
stehen lassen und wirklich bis zu
mehreren wochen lagern
falls ich figuren oder blüten
hergestellt habt die einfach ein
bisschen aus herten sollen dann lassen
sie bei raumtemperatur stehen und am
besten offen stehen aber licht geschützt
damit sie einfach durch die
sonneneinstrahlung durch das licht nicht
die farbe verlieren als die verblassen
ansonsten mit der zeit aber ansonsten
könnte die figuren und blumen wirklich
mehrere tage oder auch bis zur wochen
aufbewahren
dann solltet ihr darauf achten dass ich
so ein bisschen abdeckt mit einer
packung zum beispiel wie einfach eine
staubschicht drauf bilden
ich hoffe dass meine infos für euch
hilfreich sind und das jetzt ganz viele
tolle kreative torten dekorieren könnt
und für weitere infos schau dir einfach
auf meinem blog vorbei da steht auch
noch mal alles für euch da geht ihr
einfach auf cellestis blog.de und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim backen
und dekorieren bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss